This class is really built
around the projects.
And while there are some details that'll
change from semester to semester,
there's some principals that
we anticipate staying true for
the long run.
The first is that this project
is very open ended and
you have a lot of leeway to
specify what you want to work on.
You might choose to do some research,
you might choose to build a tool.
You might choose to investigate
a current technology,
you have a lot of room to decide what
you want to work on for the project.
You'll propose it yourself, scope it
out, develop a plan and then execute it.
Second, these projects are intended
to be real contributions to the field
of educational technology, and so
we want to do as much as possible within
the semester to get them ready
to take out into the world.
So, this class will culminate in a paper
ready for publication in the conference
or journal most pertinent to
the work you do in this class.
You don't have to submit it,
of course, but
we want to have all the work done for
you, so
that if you would like to take that
next step, you are already ready.
I'll judge the success of this class
based on the extent to which it
generates publications, research
programs, start up businesses or
tools that we can use here
in the OMSES program.
And third, just as these projects
are intended to be real contributions to
the field of educational technology,
we'd like to treat
them as such ourselves.
So with your permission, we'd like to
include your projects in our course
library, to provide to future
students in this course.
Maybe they'll borrow from your ideas.
Or maybe, some of them might
even pick up your project and
take it to the next step.